contrary to popular opinion frogs aren't
just selective eaters feasting only on
flies take the bullfrog for example
they'll eat spiders scorpions rodents
snakes fish and just about anything else
that passes in front of them but how do
they manage to be such eating machines
bullfrogs don't have big claws sharp
beaks or fangs yet they overcome pincers
poisons and spicy stingers with a mouth
as big as the great outdoors ready to
swallow just about anything
they've been known to swim 20 feet to
shore and hop an additional 15 to 20
feet grab a meal turn around and hop
back into the pond they've even been
known to stalk birds like a lion on the
prowl eating them winged beak and all
and they don't stop at their feathered
friends they'll even eat each other
a small bullfrog that doesn't watch its
step and easily become food for bigger
frog
they are quite cannibalistic a young
bullfrog must quickly learn one simple
froggy back eat whatever it wants just
don't end up on someone else's menu